Мене звати Дітмар. Я живу в Україні 10 років.
Це німець Дітмар Печ, який переїхав в Україну з Кельна в 2011-му.
55-тирічний чоловік трохи розмовляє українською, проте дуже добре її розуміє.
Крім того, прочитав майже усіх українських класиків, продивився багато чого з українського документального та художнього кіно,
навчився розписувати писанки, готувати українські страви, співати українські пісні…
У лютому 2011-му, коли Дітмар уперше приїхав в Україну у справах, а він за професією експерт з інженерного обладнання,
він і гадки не мав, що залишиться жити в цій країні, яка зустріла його тоді похмурою погодою і похмурими людьми на вулицях.
Ділові зустрічі теж видалися дивними: партнери, з якими хотіла співпрацювати його фірма, були далекі від німецької організованості та пунктуальності.
Закохатися в Україну, її ландшафти, архітектуру, людей Дітмару допомогла його дружина - українка Людмила.
Київ мене вразив, коли я приїхав вдруге.
Потім я був дуже вражений людьми і всією країною, хоча і з не дуже доброю інфраструктурою, але з надзвичайно сердечними людьми.
Також вразила місцевість, де розташований Київ і вся Україна.
Я багато подорожував, бачив поля пшениці. Я закохався в Україну. І сказав собі: "Друже, так це ж фантастична країна!"
Я цього абсолютно не очікував і не бачив нічого подібного в інших країнах.
Другого враження про Україну не зіпсувало навіть те, що одне з перших слів, яке Дітмару довелося вивчити, було "шиномонтаж".
Тоді на українських дорогах він втратив не одне колесо.
Не відлякали німця ані похмура "совкова" архітектура, ані безбарвні вулиці, ані те, що в магазинах тоді не було нормального вибору продуктів.
Дітмар став свідком, як Україною за ці 10 років керували три президенти - Янукович, Порошенко і Зеленський.
Нині, каже німець, українські дороги стали значно кращими, в магазинах можна купити що завгодно, помітно зросла якість у сфері послуг.
А на вулицях - багато яскравих, стильних, європейських людей, які набагато більше посміхаються.
Щоправда, такі зміни, на переконання Дітмара, відбулися не завдяки, а всупереч політикам.
Люди мають сьогодні більше мужності самі щось робити. У 2011-му цього взагалі не було. Тоді не було відчуття, що хтось ризикне відкрити магазин.
А сьогодні, куди б ти не прийшов, є багато маленьких фірм, які відкривають нові бізнеси і одразу ж в них реально інвестують.
Усі зміни йдуть від людей, а не від політиків, у яких є гроші, виділені МВФ абощо.
Мужність українців взяти на себе відповідальність за своє життя, родину та Батьківщину, вважає Дітмар, з’явилася після Революції Гідності,
в якій він теж брав участь. Ось, у переході під Майданом незалежності в листопаді 2013-то він разом з дружиною танцює гопака з українцями.
Революція дала поштовх багатьом НГО. Люди самі брали в свої руки турботу про міста, селища, довкілля.
Дітмар зі своєю дружиною Людмилою та друзями є активними членами руху "Екопарк Осокорки".
Вони регулярно прибирають сміття на узбережжі Дніпра та навколишніх озер, борються із забудовниками, міською владою,
аби ті не перетворили Лівобережжя у "бетоні джунглі".
Київ - на роздоріжжі. Якщо він захистить і розширить свої "зелені зони", то він має потенціал стати найзеленішим містом Європи.
Але якщо це не вдасться, якщо не стримати будівельну галузь, тоді Київ стане таким, як і багато міст у Центральній Європі.
Жахливим. Це коли немає зелені, суцільний бетон…
А це - київський ресторатор родом з Німеччини Ерік Айґнер.
Він закохався в Україну з першого погляду ще у 90-ті.
Тоді він був доволі відомою фігурою в арт-світі Києва. З його допомогою багато музикантів, художників, митців зробили собі ім’я.
Ерік - ресторатор, і свою творчу кар’єру дехто з митців починав саме в його барі.
Мене звати Соня Сотнік. Колись Ерік зробив так, що я стала барменом.
А тепер вона ведуча на Радіорокс.
А ще Айґнер зробив справжню революцію в ресторанному бізнесі Києва.
У 90-тих він популяризував ідею, що бар, паб, ресторан - це заклади для народу, а не для вибраної "еліти",
куди можна приходити в звичайних джинсах і сидіти просто на лавках, бочках і слухати живу стильну музику.
У нас був колись доволі жорсткий період. У ресторани ходили лише якісь привілейовані особи. А тут таке! Як?
Невже можна просто в барі, який у мене під будинком, прийти і поснідати?!
І це коштує дешевше, ніж піти в магазин, купити та приготувати!? І можна ще поспілкуватися?..
По суті, саме Айґнер, відкривши в 1996-му перші пивні бари в Києві, познайомив українців зі справжньою пивною культурою, як це є у Німеччині.
І з таким поняттям як коктейль.
Ми в 96-му почали перші коктейлі робити. Називалися "Очі відкриваються".
50 грамів вишневого лікеру, 50 коньяку, 50 горілки, шампанське та зверху трошки апельсинового соку.
Але випити більше двох не виходило.
З 94-го по 2014 Айґнер відкрив у Києві мережу закладів громадського харчування. Усі вони ставали успішними.
Каже, найбільший розвиток за роки його перебування в Україні спостерігав саме в ресторанній індустрії.
Також його вражає, з якою швидкістю Україну нині трансформують у цифрову державу.
Барна культура в Німеччині зараз менш розвинута, ніж в Україні. Це факт. Я можу це стверджувати, бо бачив різницю...
Там офіціанти менше спілкуються з людьми, ніж тут. В Україні все дуже інтенсивно розвивається.
Навіть у банківському секторі у ФРН все якесь застаріле. Менше розвитку інтернет-технологій.
Якщо в Німеччині не оговтаються, то незабаром почнуть відставати від усіх.
Ерік за час перебування в Україні пережив багато різних історій, пов’язаних з корупцією чиновників, зі зрадами українських партнерів по бізнесу.
За майже 20 років життя в Києві був свідком і двох українських революцій - Помаранчевої та Революції Гідності,
активно допомагав її учасникам, постачав їм гарячі обіди тощо.  Але був вимушений виїхати з країни в 2014-му...
Через свою доньку. В 2014 році до мене прийшли люди, сказали, що будуть мене "захищати", тобто "кришувати", що вони, мовляв, з Майдану.
А я сказав: не треба мене захищати. Це було, як на початку 90-тих, коли бандити приходили і казали, що будуть твоєю охоронною фірмою...
І тоді я сказав, що ні, не хочу знову в 90-ті...
Тепер донька виросла, і Ерік зі своїм собакою Мексом через 7 років знову приїхав в Україну.
Працевлаштувався в своїй галузі - працює керівником у барі свого колишнього учня на Подолі.
Каже, що значних змін після семи років відсутності не відчув.
Окей, подивимося, чи є порядок у барі.
Ксюшо, поміняй ці склянки.
Ерік в усьому цінує насамперед порядок.
Каже, що якщо умовно порівняти теперішню Україну із занедбаним баром, який би йому доручили відновити,
то він би в першу чергу вигнав старий персонал, який довів паб до такого стану, а потім почистив би усе з віником.
Конкретно проблема - в корупції. Це постійна зміна законів і не в кращий бік. Видно, що це робиться на користь окремих депутатів.
Якийсь загальний безлад. А у безладі легше наживатися, усім це вигідно.
Німецький ресторатор каже, що йому відверто боляче спостерігати за тим, як українська влада ставиться до своїх громадян.
Пенсіонери, приміром. Пенсія 2000 грв. Це ж смішно. Якщо комунальні послуги коштують тисячу гривень. Я не знаю, як це назвати.
І ці ж люди працювали на країну. Молодь розвинута. Але чомусь багато хто виїхав у Польщу. І у Польщі працюють. Чимала кількість.
Не сто тисяч, а мільйони. Це теж знак, на жаль. Якщо Україна не може утримати свою молодь. Але сподіваємось, як завжди, на краще.
Обидва німці впевнені, що Україна ще далеко не розкрила свій потенціал.
Головне багатство країни - це люди, яких ці німці обожнюють.
І українські ресурси, зокрема чорноземи, які, як вважають німці, дають найкращі врожаї у світі.
Дружина Дітмара Людмила каже, що серед її знайомих-німців, які працюють та живуть в Україні, майже немає тих, які хотіли б виїхати з України.
Наразі вони, мабуть, більше вірять у нашу країну, ніж ми самі…
Ерік Айґнер взагалі каже, що повернувся в Україну назавжди.
І серйозно налаштований вивчити українську мову, яку він добре розуміє, але погано говорить.
Чому я повернувся? Тому що це моя Батьківщина. Батьківщина для мене - не там, де народився, а там, де тобі добре.
30-ть років незалежної України - це ще не той термін, коли можна говорити про завершення розбудови країни, кажуть німці.
Вони впевнені, що найцікавіші зміни ще попереду.
І сподіваються, що у наступні десять років влада в Україні нарешті почне не на словах, а на ділі служити народу, а не обслуговувати власні інтереси.
І що те, що виборювали дві революції на Майдані, нарешті здійсниться.